哈喽大家好，欢迎收听本期的饭来张口，我是老饭。
我是雪梨。
咱们这一期又该聊聊吃了。
据理我们上一次聊吃已经过去了三四期了。
咱们上一次还是聊的是中华料理。
对。
那咱上一期也说了，聊完了中华料理，那这一期就该聊一聊啥呢？
正经的中餐。
这是八经中餐了。
当然了，也有那些不正经的中餐。
这二八经的中餐又不正经的。
不正经的中餐里面也有正经。
那么今天这期节目，我们就来聊一聊。
我们在日本这么多年，给我们留下深刻印象的中餐馆。
先跟大家说一下我和雪梨的一个情况。
我和雪梨在当初上学的时候，都不在东京。
她在大阪上学，然后我是在石川县，一个比较偏僻的一个地方。
那么先从上学的时候开始聊吧。
我上学那会儿吧。
我记得第一家印象特别深刻的一个中餐馆，是一个在南坡这条街上一个门两非常小的一个东北菜馆。
当时呢，这个物价也不是很贵。
中午的时候和晚上她都有这个定时的套餐。
每一份大概都是九百八或者八百八，最便宜的甚至有七百八的。
这么便宜呢？
你记得大阪的石心大概是多少？
我当时的话是在药装店打工，石心大概是在一千一，后来去了大国给了一千三。
哪一年啊？
一八年。
这么高吗？
当时低于一千的我们都不去。
我还记得当时我们同学里面大概得有一半都是在药装店打工的，是因为他的石心给的特别高。
咱俩是在一个日本吗？
我学校那边的便利店的价格是八百多，药装店是九百多。
你这就是低保护啊？
我在基尤打工那是我周边最高的了，一千一个小时吗？
我们当然是首选药装店，是因为它最低最低是一千一，然后到深夜的时候会给到一千三。
也有可能是因为大板嘛，毕竟是大城市。
对，因为它这个最低的这个石心就已经很高了。
还有一些同学会选一些餐饮店，或者说是烧烤店，还有一些服装店。
这样的店它就没有这么高，大概是在一千上下，它会包一顿饭。
够我喝得好？
对，包括在那些便利店打工的会有那些每天剩下的那些东西。
所以基本上就是一个小时的工资就可以正儿八经的吃一顿饭？
可以吃一顿定食。
所以当时这个恒远小吃的这个店基本上就是我怎么说打工之后，
然后尤其是发了工资以后，有了钱了会选择去吃一顿定食，为什么呢？
是因为我当时一个月的伙食费大概是一万到一万五日元。
不是因为我没有这个钱，是因为我不太舍得花。
一个月一万到一万五的话，那一天就是三百到五百。
对。
那这你每天吃啥呢？
我当时甚至觉得自己吃得还不错呢。
在超市会买一些豆腐、豆芽、青菜，回家一煮。
有时候给自己弄个底料，弄个火锅。
不是，过得这么惨吗？
但是当时我确实不觉得惨。
所以那个七百块钱的那个定食就已经算你改善生活了呗？
就是这意思。
所以那个时候我是心情特别好，或者说是打工发了工资以后，
我觉得想吃巨资去吃一顿好的了，
然后会选择这家恒远小吃点一份定食。
我特别喜欢吃他们家的酸菜白肉的定食。
今天发工资，请自己吃一顿酸菜白肉。
差不多，我有很多次都是这样子。
知道你是在日本打工，不知道你以为你在农村打工呢？
差不多。
而且当十一八年在大阪，
虽然说它是一个非常繁华的一个城市，
但是大阪市里面还没有特别多的中餐馆。
18年，这个就是我的忙去。
确实，你那边到现在可能都没有什么中餐馆。
然后这个酸菜白肉吧，我为什么点它呢？
是因为我特别喜欢吃酸菜。
当时呢，物产店的酸菜也好像没有那么多。
就是我能买到的机会好像也不多。
再加上它这个白肉吧，
这个猪肉放的这个量也特别大。
所以我就觉得整个人的一盆，
有肉有菜有粉条，
满满的一大碗九百八，
我觉得特别实惠。
所以时不时的两三个月，
会靠老自己这么一次。
味道呢？
味道很好吃，
然后这家店的这个老板和老板娘，
还经常手做一些包子呀饺子。
都是你看着他在那个后厨自己家包的。
我有时候也会买两三个回家，
然后当早餐吃。
啊，你没多买点冻钱。
冰箱小冻不下。
我的啥日子我的天啊。
而且基本上也很近吧，
就到我家也就是个三四站。
因为我们打工全在那个南坡新宅桥，
就是最繁华的那个区域嘛。
所以呢，基本上每天都会去，
什么时候想吃了就买两个回家就很方便。
我对这个电机还特别深刻的是，
当时他们那个儿子吧，
还是上高中。
一八年上高中的话，
现在也大一毕业了吧。
对，差不多了。
所以上次咱们去路过那家店的时候，
我还特意看了一眼，
他们家儿子还在那帮忙呢，
在那个店的外边，
好像正烤串呢。
那个店还在那，
还在那，
这么多年了，
就是特别不起眼的一个小门链。
但是就是这么不起眼的一个门链，
也确实承载了我留学的时候，
非常重要的几年的一个回忆。
你去到那的时候，
他就已经在，
他那只开多少年你知道？
还真不知道，
就没问过，
但确实是有年头了。
我没注意，
上回咱们去的时候，
你说那个店，
所以在你的记忆中，
他那个门头或者装潢变了？
没变,
还是你记忆中的样子？
对，还是我记忆中的那个装修，
包括他这个店旁边那些店，
都已经不知道换了多少代了，
这个店还是记忆中的样子。
这个也是很难得的，
现在更新，
换代这么快，
尤其日本的中餐这么卷，
咱不能说，
一两个月就换一批吧，
但基本上你过个半年一年的，
一条街的店铺，
基本就换一茬儿了。
对,
所以呢，
这个店就是当时印象非常深刻的，
也是我第一次，
去中餐馆吃饭，
然后还有一个印象很深刻的店，
就是张亮麻辣烫了。
18年就张亮麻辣烫了吗，日本？
有。
这么早就有了？
对。
我对他印象非常深刻，
是因为我每天去上班的这个路上，
他是毕竟之路，
每天都能够看到他，
但是呢，
我一次都没进去过。
为什么？
是因为他外边看起来，
就跟国内差不多，
就是什么招牌，
但是这个门脸看上去，
就不是特别的干净卫生。
那不就是跟国内一样？
就是一次让我想进去的这个欲望都没有。
那这多正宗？
反而那种特别干净的就不正宗了？
你换而这么说，
但是,
他当时门口不是有这个菜单吗？
我看见这个价格之后，
就给我圈退了。
当时那个汤底大概是九百八还是一千多。
啥汤底一千多？
现在一千多也不便宜，
别说一八年了。
然后这个菜还要另外去收费，
所以我就觉得我没有必要，
我吃个麻辣汤花个两千或者三千，
所以这就导致我一次都没有进去过。
那确实也没有必要，
他要是一个汤底就一千多呢？
所以咱们上次去大阪的时候，
那张量麻辣汤还在吗？
还在,
然后在他的旁边，
有一栋这个购物的一栋大楼，
这栋大楼是所有的这个去大阪的中国流团，
会扎垫的地方。
怎么叫扎垫？
就是购物团带着去这些店去买东西的地方，
他的一楼开了一家洗茶之前。
我好像知道了，
是那个咱俩想去买个洗茶，
然后看里面太脏就走了那个吗？
扎垫的整个的那些东西全让给中国人准备了，
然后在这家洗茶的旁边，
好像还开了一个养国服，
好像还有一个小肥养，
如果我没有记错的话，
就是最近几年，
确实也开了不少新店，
他都我不知道，
但是那个洗茶真的有五脏有五乱，
就是他店里面的装修果觉得还好，
但就是那个顾客坐在座位上喝完的那些杯子，
袋子，吸管，
就那么怂怒妈妈的放在那，
然后那个服务员站里面，
那玩手机也不说出来收拾，
就是感觉这个店像快倒闭的一样那种，
它不像一个正在营业的那个店，
你能想象吧，
就是一个店快倒闭了里面那种脏，
乱的那种情况，
就跟那个一样的。
对，所以它根本就不是非常注重用户的体验，
就是当时我留学的时候印象深刻的第二家店，
然后随着这个留学的年数的增加，
大阪这边的中餐馆开的也越来越多了。
还有一家是一家烧烤店，
它叫上上千，
我不知道现在还有没有啊，
这家店是疫情的时候，
我们发现的一个店，
当时也是开业的时候，
在网上有一些铺天盖地的宣传，
我们也抱着双高的期望。
不过这个店确实也没踩雷，
因为它是当时大阪少有的几家，
做的比较不错的烧烤店，
它的味道做的也很重重，
虽然这个店确实也不大，
包括到当时还卖一些手工的凉皮，
然后炸鸡排，炸鸡柳，
这些东西在当时的大阪，
确实也是比较少见的东西，
就是你可能想吃，就是也买不着，
然后这个味也调得很重纵，
就凉皮是那种甜辣口，
也是我很喜欢那种味道。
所以这家店也是后来几年，
每次想吃烧烤的时候，
我们一定会去的这么一个店，
它当时火到什么地步呢，
就是你每次想去之前，
你要先在微信去跟他们预约，
或者先去打电话，
如果你说当天我想去这家店去吃饭，
那一定是没有位置的，
甚至你可能要排到晚上10点多，
才能有位置让你进去吃饭，
也有可能是当时的大阪，
确实没有几家正宗的烧烤店，
就实在是没得吃了，
对，当时一串羊，
串好像是150吧，
就那个时候还没长假吗，
现在肯定是长假了，
现在150可下不来，
现在250下来多少便宜呢，
对，但是当时我在吃这家店的时候呢，
我的手里面就稍微能有点闲钱了，
能给我花几千块钱，
然后让自己去吃一顿好的烧烤了，
就是我的生活慢慢的就开始改善了，
所以是因为收入变多了，
舍得花钱了，
收入其实没有变特别多，
就是还是舍得花钱了，
那为啥之前不舍得花，
后来舍得花了呢，
我觉得实在是太扣搜了，
感觉对不起自己了，
我觉得我过的什么日子呀，
那时候，
确实过的啥日子呀，
所以后来慢慢的就，
把每个月的预算稍微往上调了一点，
大概到2万到3万之间，
这个时候就吃得非常不错了，
这就是一家烧烤店，
像其他的一些店，
可能就没有什么太值得说的必要，
就是一些大家都很常见的东北菜，
但是那个时候没去，
也是因为它这个人均会很贵，
因为一道菜那时候都得一千多块钱嘛，
那个时候就得一千多，
现在可能奔着两千就去了，
所以那个时候，
就算去这家店吃饭的话，
一顿下来，
人均也得三四千块钱，
那这的话，
可能说起吃中餐，
还是属于一种改善生活的一种心态，
那个时候可太改善生活了，
所以我可以花钱去吃烧烤，
因为烧烤人均下来没有这么贵，
但是我确实是舍不得花三四千去吃一顿炒菜，
对比而言的话，
其实内置鸡也加一碗牛肉饭的话，
也就四百多日元，
对,
吃一个套餐的话，
大概也就七八百，
对,
所以人均三四千，
确实是一笔巨款，
内置三四千日元的话，
基本上就可以吃一顿烤肉自助了，
对,
但是那个时候，
慢慢的就会有一些新兴的东西出来了，
就比如说，
它开始有卖肉夹馍的，
有卖螺丝粉的，
一八年那时候还没有呢，
也有可能是有，
但是我没找着，
我知道肉夹馍和螺丝粉的时候，
是在二零年以后了，
这种产品二零年以后才登陆日本，
才走入大众市野，
然后那个时候买一个肉夹馍，
几百,
螺丝粉一份也是几百，
但是那个螺丝粉我真的不推荐，
因为,
它煮的那个，
就是在后厨，
把那个螺丝粉的那个包撕开了，
煮好之后再端给你的，
你别说内置了，
现在也是，
就没有任何的改变，
对,
但那个时候呢，
我就觉得新鲜嘛，
所以,
体验一下还是非常不错的，
确实,
内置说起螺丝粉，
还是比较新鲜的一个东西，
对,
包括那个时候，
还出现了一两家，
比较好吃的，
兰州牛肉面的店，
我最常去的那一家，
我现在已经忘了叫什么名字了，
但是我对它这个味道，
还是记忆非常深刻的，
它这个位置呢，
也在这个难剥里边，
难剥怎么这么多中餐，
因为它是最繁华的地段，
就这个区域，
集中了，
大阪几乎所有的中餐，
这家牛肉面店，
我为什么记忆特别深刻呢，
是因为它是一家，
东北人开的，
兰州牛肉面的店，
它特别的不正宗，
就是不正宗到，
我进到店，
我说我要一碗，
二戏的牛肉面，
我就眼睁睁地看见，
它在后厨，
把牛肉面这个底料，
罐打开了，
底料罐，
然后给我挽了两勺这个，
汤底的这个粉，
然后加了点水，
和冷和冷，
又随便称了点面，
就放进去，
就给我端上来了，
我要的是二戏，
然后我朋友说我要的是三戏，
结果我们把这个面，
一对比一看，
哎，一样粗，
什么二戏三戏，
个嘴里都得嚼，
你就吃吧，
就是虽然它非常的不正宗，
但是我当时，
确实也觉得很好吃，
是因为，
我确实也没有别的。
牛肉面店，
可以选了，
甚至每次去的时候，
都会有一种，
很亲切的感觉，
哎呀，吃到国内的味道了，
觉得很欣慰，
我也从来没有想吐槽，
他说,
你这个人做的怎么那么难吃，
什么的，
从来没有过，
还轮不到挑的时候，
对,
先有的吃再说，
已经很满足了，
但是这种心情，
直到到了东京，
我发现居然有
这么多的牛肉面店的时候，
我才会觉得说，
哎，有的选了，
你不仅有的选了，
甚至我们还批判一份，
你都有空间，
开始挑三减四了，
可想而知，
这日子也算是好起来的，
是吧,
然后这就是一家
牛肉面的店，
当时我记得，
在这个闹市区，
就是那个新宅桥，
那个桥上面，
就是有格力高小儿的那个，
对面有一栋楼，
在这个楼的这个，
顶楼,
好像是七楼，
八楼,
有一家餐厅，
叫中国茶房，
中国茶房，
吃啥呢，
它名字叫中国茶房，
它是一家，
主打吃，
炒菜和北京烤鸭的一家店，
这个店其实也很有意思，
我第一次去的时候，
是跟朋友一块儿去的，
去了之后一进去，
我就傻眼了，
它这个店，
其实是一个成人俱乐部改的，
就是你一进去，
它这个墙壁上，
全是马赛克，
全是不可说的东西，
因为它这个硬装改不了，
就是你要砸墙，
你进去装修的话，
肯定要费笔钱，
所以他们就把这个东西保留着了，
但是一些太漏骨的东西，
又在那儿很炸眼不好看，
怎么办呢，
这些店家呢，
就给这些东西忽略层布，
就遮上了，
知道什么叫史上雕花，
差不多，
反正都是下三路的东西，
这家店，
我们当时因为人多嘛，
因为同学聚餐，
所以还点了一整套烤鸭，
当时那一套好像是五千九百八，
一整只，
然后还有饼啊，
还有小料什么的，
那还行，不贵，
确实是不贵，
五千九百八，
六千块钱，
按当时的汇率，
不也就三百多块钱了，
对呀,
但是当时我就觉得，
我天呐，
我的生活已经变这么好了嘛，
居然可以点一整套烤鸭，
丁西姐不能让你妈听，
我妈听见心碎了，
哎呀,
我姑娘这是过的啥日子呀，
她也知道我是纯坤，
有好日子不好过，
所以当时也是，
第一次在日本吃到烤鸭，
所以味道呢？
就还行吧，
有吃的已经很满足了，
没有什么可挑的，
就是谈不上难吃，
能吃,
对,
那其实感觉烤鸭，
到现在也没有什么进步，
到现在也，
第一个烤鸭店也不多，
第二个味也就那样，
对呀,
看来烤鸭店，
在日本可以再卷一卷，
啥时候，
你像什么，
大董啊，
人巨德呀，
那他们是有多想不开呀，
都在日本开店了，
那就行了，
但是中华街，
有400亿卷的这个，
北京烤鸭卷，
那你就算了吧，
那还能叫烤鸭呀，
就日本去尝个香，
我觉得还是可以的，
虽然跟正宗的烤鸭，
没有什么关系啊，
反正就是日本人
特别喜欢的那个味道，
所以这些就是，
到现在为止，
我脑袋里面，
对于大阪的这个中餐馆的，
印象特别深刻的几个店，
最后还有一个，
就是海底捞儿了，
哦对,
你在大阪，
你能吃到海底捞儿，
对，说起来呢，
因为我是18年4月份去的嘛，
海底捞儿呢，
是18年10月份的时候，
在大阪开的店，
所以其实我刚去不久，
哎，他就开业了，
海底捞儿看你去了，
赶紧在大阪开一个店，
然后那个时候呢，
第一次去也是跟同学们。
一块儿去的，
因为尝虾嘛，
毕竟他都已经在大阪开店了，
那不去就对不起他，
是不是，
然后当时去的时候，
其实心里面还，
有种小机动，
就觉得，
哎，我居然可以在。
海外吃到海底捞儿的味道，
就很亲切，
也想看看海底捞儿火锅这种东西，
在国外到底能开成什么样子，
然后去了几个人点了一下，
确实很好吃，
跟国内味也差不多，
包括他还有一些，
可能国内有了一些，
什么变脸节目啊，
还有传统那个撑面呢，
哎，都非常好，
但是唯一的一个不好的点呢，
我觉得就是贵，
那不是他的缺点，
那是你的缺点，
不好意思，不错，
对不起，
你反思一下你自己，
当时人真低顿好像吃了得有，
六千多块钱，
你放现在也不便宜啊，
你别说那这儿了，
所以我当时对海底捞儿这个，
出体验的这种感觉呢，
就是太贵了，
我可能一年，
能吃个一次两次，
过年了，
听见了吗，胖子，
吃到海底捞儿就算过年了，
哎,
反观是我爹妈，
其实比我更早吃的海底捞儿，
是因为这家电视，
18年10月份的时候，
在大阪开的，
东京时代，
在15年的时候就已经开了，
所以我爸妈当时4月份，
刚把我送到大阪，
哎，把我安顿好，
他们两个人就很潇洒的，
去东京旅游了，
然后走到持在的时候发现，
哎，有家海底捞儿，
顺便去吃一顿，
吃一顿之后发现，
确实挺贵的，
两人花了七百多块钱，
这件事我知道，
你们见过那个黑人问号脸吗，
当时许雷跟我说的时候，
我就是那个表情的，
我理解不了，
为什么来东京旅游，
我要吃海底捞儿，
这就跟我第一次吃海底捞儿的，
这种心情是一样的，
不一样，怎么可能一样，
就是你爸妈是来旅游的，
我为什么来这儿旅游，
我还要吃一顿海底捞儿，
我吃点别的不好吗，
其实我们的心情是差不多的，
就是因为海底捞儿是一个。
我们非常熟悉的一个品牌，
他在国内我们已经吃了无数次了，
那么他在海外开店了之后，
我们对他抱有的一种心奇，
好奇,
想体验一下这个火锅在海外，
是一种什么样的感觉，
然后发现，
平平无奇，
但就是在海外吃海底捞儿的体验，
不太一样，
所以就是抱着一种烈奇的心态吗，
对,
就是一个好奇心，
那发现，
跟国内别无二致的时候，
会不会有些许失望，
不会啊，
因为海底捞儿，
我能想象到它是什么样的味道，
它只要能做得不出错，
它就已经赢了，
我要的只是在，
一国它像体验海底捞儿的这么一个感觉，
所以你问过你爸，
你妈当时为啥要去？
就是因为好奇啊，
他们甚至全程还给我直播了，
今天我们点了什么锅底，
点了几个菜，
最后花了多少钱，
体验怎么样，
服务怎么样，
就其实你能感觉到。
他们两个的心情，
也是很激动，
很开心的，
然后后来，
我在第二次在去，
大阪的还聊吃饭的时候，
我就已经发现，
它有这个学生卡，
打八五折的活动了，
所以那个时候，
确实也拯救了我不太富裕的钱包，
打完折也很贵，
对，打完折，
依旧是一年去一两次，
那其实我对海底捞儿的印象，
怎么说呢，除了贵，
还有一个点就是，
它这个小老台，
怎么说呢，
一眼难进吧，
尤其是水果那个区域，
也能理解，
在日本，
水果本来就贵，
对,
但是你也不能把
东西和黄瓜一起上来啊，
就是它实在没得摆了，
只能拿那些来冲冲树，
你也不能光涂涂地在那摆着吧，
然后就是一些橙子，
和很难吃的西柚，
这两个好像一直都有，
好一点的话，
可能就是在夏天的时候，
会有一些冷冻的栗汁，
或者菠萝，
反正西瓜你肯定别想了，
那这个不可能了，
想都别想，
开玩笑，
对,
这个就是跟国内
可能不太一样的店，
然后再后来呢，
东京可能就，
这些店出了一些，
优惠的一些套餐，
打折的活动，
那个时候吃，
就挺便宜的了，
两个人如果，
入门级别的，
随便小吃一顿的话，
大概花个六千多左右，
然后再后来，
像这几年的话，
还来就出了一些，
自热火锅，
就慢慢的可以在
家门口的超市啊，
便利店都可以买得到了，
包括现在，
急运啊，
还有无产店都非常丰富了，
那么，自己能选择的范围，
也就越来越多了，
那种就应该有无产店了呀，
但是它品类没有那么丰富，
而且我们那个无产店，
特别贵，
中国人装扣中国人，
对,
也能理解，
很难想像一个，
海底捞的，
素食火锅，
中国人开的无产店，
要比日本的超市里面还得贵，
那这都是常态，
所以这些呢，
就是在我留学的时候，
在大板记忆深刻的一些店，
那跟你比我的，
就没啥可说的了，
我那山里头就有一个中国人，
开的一个店，
一个东北人，
开的一个台湾料理，
东北人看的一个台湾料理，
它不能是吃中华的吧，
就是吃中华的，
平时去那个店里面，
也都是日本人，
附近村的呀，
工作的呀，
去哪儿吃的，
所以它那个菜单，
菜单也都是那种日式中华那种菜单，
然后呢，
因为呢，
它离我们学校比较近，
但是这个近，
不代表走路能到，
所以呢，
就是经常会有开车的同学，
带一些梅克的同学，
一起去那儿，
改善生活，
那山里面真的没得吃，
你别说中华料理了，
正经的餐馆，
我们方圆五公里之内，
也就那么一两家，
那你这日子过了，
相对于我来说，
你这更贫穷吗？
对,
我去那儿就是改善生活去的，
你就是真的改善生活，
但是价格确实不贵，
你看那这儿的话，
我们吃一个套餐，
大概也就是七八百，
日式中华那种，
一份麻婆豆腐，
一份米饭，
一个小咸菜，
然后一碗汤，
这么一个sitle，
大概是七百多日元，
然后呢，
中国留学生去得多了，
或者去的时间长了，
我们就开始给老板提要求了，
我要吃这个，我要吃那个，
这就是有一种亲切感，
东北人也比较热情开了，
所以呢，去了多呢，
我们就熟悉了，
然后呢，
我们就开始给老板提一些过分的要求，
老板能不能做这个呀，
老板能不能做那个呀，
什么第三鲜，
锅包肉呀，
什么水煮鱼，
水煮肉片就开始要求起来了，
我老板说，
有你们是我的福气，
第一个那个店，
它本来就不贵，
第二个呢，
那个老板娘人也比较好，
她也不会漫天要价，
以至于我们给老板提要求的时候呢，
我们没想到多少钱，
多少钱都行，
你要能做就行，
这有的吃就可以了，
确实那这也不贵，
因为那这没有那个菜单，
我们那有唇药，
那真的是我们点什么人做什么，
然后那这的话，
也就是七八百，
像锅包肉的话，
可能一千左右，
然后像什么，
公报鸡丁呀，
鱼香鸡丝呀，
像这种菜头，
一般都是七八百八九百，
一开始人还少，
也还好，
但你价不住一传十十传百，
就以至于到后来，
我们需要中国人，
全去那家店，
就导致老板也遭不住了，
因为他是啥呢，
会有一个问题，
就是他有的时候，
那个价格不一定是一样的，
就比如你去这个，
老板说，
得公报鸡丁八百，
下次换一个去，
可能那几天的成本上来了，
那可能就说九百，
哎，不对啊，
那天我们怎么吃八百呢，
或者说那天我们那同学，
过来怎么就八百，
你怎么要我九百呢，
会有这种人，
知道吧，
所以他那个时候，
也没有说，
定一个统一的定价，
他连菜单都没有，
我怎么给你定价，
然后后来老板觉得，
这样也不太好，
然后就写了另一份菜单，
隐藏菜单，
哎,
正常的那个日式中华，
还在那，
然后呢，他就会，
再做出来一张，
那是熟写的，
中国人来了，
你就看这个菜单，
然后日本来了，
给你看那个菜单，
后来他又开始，
不光是在店里做了，
他就开始给我们学校送餐了，
哦，还开始有配送服务了，
哎,
你看人老板会做生意，
你知道吧，
勾起啊，
人家知道，
我们需要出行不太便利，
没车的同学呢，
可能不太方便来了一个店，
吃饭啥的呢，
可能都不是那么顺口，
学校附近的，
也没有什么能吃的，
所以呢，
他后来弄了个微信群，
每天早上起来群里边发，
我们今天做什么菜，
他会给你组成一个一份便当，
大概是三个菜，
一个饭那么一份，
然后有500的，
700的,
900的,
你可以挑，
当然不光都是那个。
正儿八经的中菜，
它里面还有炸鸡啊，
你们炸春卷啊，
去看你要哪个，
像这种半成品，
它都会有背的嘛，
所以呢，
他就顺便都在里面做了，
凑成了这么三份套餐，
你要哪个在群里面说，
哎，我要A，
套餐A,
我要套餐B，
然后中午12点，
他开车到学校门口，
交钱取东西，
那个店就养活了一个学校，
那简直就是你们食堂，
对,
我那种过去还是比较方便的，
一个是我不住学校里面，
第二个那种我也有车，
所以呢，
我跟那个老板，
就是熟悉的比较早，
然后有一次那个老板去钓鱼去，
钓完了以后，
他就给我发微信，
你钓鱼嘛，
我说啥鱼，
我说河鱼刚钓上来的，
胖头鱼有多大呢，
大概有我小臂这么长，
哦，那很大了，
哦,
多少钱？
不知道，
因为日本人不吃河鱼，
是,
他们总觉得这个鱼有个土行味，
以至于啥呢，
日本的河里面的鱼都特别肥，
拿过来了以后，
我说老板多少钱，
老板看看，
500日元完了，
啊，还要500日元，
500日元,
嫩大一条鱼，
我要两条，
那你回家就给它炖了，
红烧了，
然后我熟试那个鱼的时候，
我才发现那个鱼，
满满的籽，
等我按钮，
你摆肚子抛开，
那个籽就流出来了，
哎呦，给我美的呀，
我说改善生活了，
但你中体验也是，
普通留学生可能体验不到的，
对,
这个就是说到，
虽然地方小，
但是就会有一种，
归属感和亲切感在这，
就是那个餐馆，
到后来已经不是我们，
为了吃饭的一个地方了，
它就像是一个啥呢，
还像一个句点一样，
比如说疫情那几年，
不是,
出行不太方便吗，
然后呢，
那个老板就在他们店里面，
搞那个，
就算是春节晚会嘛，
就是,
我不知道那个形容，
就算是一个大聚会吧，
他会在群里面说，
就是谁想报名，
比如说三十晚上的那个聚餐，
然后大概一个人是，
一两千吧，
然后有好多菜可以随便吃，
他店里面呢，
会放一个大的一个投影，
但是放那个春节晚会，
大家在里面吃啊，
聊啊，玩啊什么的，
很亲切啊，
因为他那个店，
不是在山里吗，
所以呢，
最不缺的就是地，
他那个店的厅长要比店大，
然后呢，
他挂的那个，
红灯笼，
远处一看，
喜气扬扬的，
就看那个店，
农家乐啊，简直是，
一样,
然后那天晚上，
停了好多车在那，
全是人，
听起来怎么像是一个什么，
某某神秘组织，
一个街头的句点，
可热闹，
那一屋的人，
就是好多人，
谁跟谁都不认识，
但是到时候一吃饭，
就能聊到一块儿去，
就很奇怪，
甚至说，
你今天喝完了，
聊完了，吃完立顿饭走了，
好，这人叫什么，
不知道，
你都不知道人叫啥，
然后,
到了后来，
我们不是在山里吗，
那个城市里头，
又开了一个中餐，
是因为我们学校附近的那家，
开展了这个送餐业务，
就导致啥呢，
有同学去城里面玩啊，
逛啊,
看起有那么个中餐，
然后在那里面一聊，
说我们学校门口有送餐的，
然后每天怎么样呢，
就导致那个店，
也看着帮你送，
有竞争了开始，
对对对，
那个店送的，
不仅是便当了，
开始有什么烤串啊，
小龙虾，
就开始陆陆虚虚的种类，
就丰富起来了，
那生活改善的非常好了，
对对对，
就发现商机了也是，
你知道吧，
后来这个城里这个店，
做的要比我们学校门口那个好，
是因为啥呢，
它不仅是送餐，
什么烤串也送，
还有小龙虾，
然后后来还送什么麻辣鸭货，
人家自己做的，
不是那种劲的货啊，
就是自己做的麻辣鸭货，
然后还有什么物产，
它都开始送，
就你要啥，
你跟他说他就给你送来，
然后呢，
就在那个家买的，
人就越来越多了，
就导致后来，
我们学校门口的那家老板，
就不做了，
人家做这个事，
更多的就是，
为了照顾学生，
然后你这样有竞争的话呢，
第一个我本来就不挣那么多钱，
第二个我现在，
有竞争不就卷起来了吗，
我没必要跟你在这儿争，
你要累做你就做，
我就不做了，
我再收拾点挺好的，
然后后来人就不送了，
但是我们去呢，
还是会去那家店，
就是因为熟悉了在那，
但是后来的同学，
就是我的后辈们，
更多的就是买城里那一家，
在他们看来，
可能城里那一家，
可能就是种类权一点，
味道好一点，
这儿大概就是这样，
但可能对于我们来说的话，
那个意义就不一样，
基本上就完了，
我城里就没了，
咱都不是说，
你能不能吃到的问题，
就是没有，
什么海底捞，
什么牛肉面，
没见过，
不好意思，
火锅都没有，
那跟你这么一对比的话，
我觉得我这个留学的体验，
确实也很不错了，
因为他吃不到，
这也造就了我，
什么都会做，
练就了一身厨艺，
这也侧面成就了我，
现在基本上吃啥都能做，
就是逼出来的，
在山里边这几年逼出来的，
实在是没有吃的，
有的话也不是这么的，
进入人意，
然后到了二，
一年还是二零年，
那是一行，
政府不知道发了好多那个流卷，
然后我就去大板玩了一圈，
我想着，
毕业了去东京，
可能来关系不是特别方便，
然后从需要那边比较近，
所以我就开车，
去大板玩一圈，
我去之前做计划的时候，
我就没想着说，
我去哪玩，
看啥景，
我就存在那搜有什么中餐，
你就纯是为了吃中餐觉得？
对,
也不是说为了吃中餐，
但是纯为了吃，
那么大板的张一丸子，
还有那个神作的拉面，
人家伊兰都在我的计划之内，
但是是纯为了吃去的，
而不是说纯为了吃中餐，
你说这几年给这孩子逼人什么样啊？
当然不是说山里面什么也没有啊，
就是你往城里面走一走的话，
什么烤肉呀，拉面呀，
还是有的，
只是说那些大品牌的连锁不一定有，
就比如说伊兰，
海底罗尔克，
像这种店肯定是没有的，
但是最基本的，
普通的烤肉店，
普通的拉面店，
或者说是
玉三加啥的，
肯定是有的。
对,
但是你吃几年毕竟还是会吃腻的吗？
对对对，
你可选择性比较少，
而且还有一个，
我觉得跟城市不一样，
就是那个地方的店都特别稳定，
稳定到我的学长们，
他们入学的时候吃这个店，
一直到我走了以后来的后备们，
吃的还是这些店，
甚至连菜单都没变，
那肯定，
就那几家店，
对,
它就很稳定，
它的更新换代非常的慢，
所以呢，
我去大阪，
其实更多的是吃那些我平时吃不到的那些，
然后到了大阪以后，
我吃到了一个，
我到现在为止，
吃到的最好吃的一个炸串，
当然我说的这个最好吃，
不算天津的那个炸串，
因为天津的炸串对我来说已经不是好吃了，
它更多的是一种寄托，
咱只谈味道的话，
我在大阪吃到了我这辈子觉得最好吃的一个炸串，
是在一个小民房里，
然后屋里面也不是特别的整洁干净吧，
然后一个奶奶带着她的儿子在开店那个店，
基本上她儿子在后厨做东西，
然后奶奶在前面招呼客人，
那奶奶非常的慈祥，
那个味道我没有办法形容，
但就是特别的好吃，
大连的一个炸串，
特别好吃，
然后他们所有的食材都是自己做的，
包括他们灌汤包啊，
闷子呀什么的，
全是那个儿子自己做的，
然后走的时候，
那个奶奶也特别亲切的给我送到门口，
看着我下楼，
这个店以至于我后来修电脑的时候，
又跑了一趟大阪的那个苹果店，
本来的计划是我去那儿修完电脑就回来，
一天往返，
就在那儿这么一会儿工夫，
我就跑那个店又吃了一顿，
可见他在你心中是有多么高的地位，
然后咱们上次去的时候，
我再找那个店，那个店关门了，
对，但是好像你找到了他们的那个老板啊，
对，我找那个老板，
那个老板也不干餐饮了，
他去卖房子了，
然后那个店也不干了，
他的妈妈呢在一个居酒屋里面，
现在帮忙，
然后我也就没去了，
就觉得有点可惜，
对，毕竟味道这么好呢，
对,
然后我在大阪也吃了一个拉面，
但是那拉面在哪儿我还不太知道，
但是整个体验非常糟糕，
我去的时候是夏天，
然后他那个店是长条型的，
他那个空调开点不是特别足，
里面那个后厨搞得整个店特别热，
因为你外面太热了，
我刚进那个店的时候，
是那一瞬间是凉快的，
但是你往那一坐，
那个热气就轰上来了，
然后那个热腾的那个面在端上来，
我感觉那顿饭就吃的在煎哦，
就是我完全没有心情去品尝他的味道，
我只想就是赶紧吃完赶紧走，
再受罪，
就是存在受罪了，
对于味道的话，我已经没有记忆了，
反正我到现在记忆中能想到的，
就是那家店的体验非常糟糕，
我觉得我们两个在大阪的这些体验好像都不太一样，
不一样，
因为我去的时候就是拿谷歌地图搜，
因为那边我也不知道什么小红书啊，
什么抖音乱七八糟的吧，
我只能在谷歌搜，
然后我就看那些评价，
评价高的我就去，
大概就是那样，
所以其实我上学的时候，
吃的大多数的中餐还是在大阪，
我在学校吃的可能更多的就是，
中国人做的菜，
对，他也算中餐，
但是可能不管是味道啊，
还是条件都有限吧，
这么一笔的话，我那时候其实还挺幸福的，
我甚至后来还可以买到可可，
然后还有共茶，
还有几家他们自己开的奶茶店，
什么杨之干鹿啊，
奥里奥奶茶啊，
这都是我每天，
想喝的时候就可以买得到的东西，
你这过得太幸福了，
不一样，
我那边上学的时候真的啥也没有，
你家我去大阪，
吃东西那次都已经是二二一年了，
我一七年就到那儿呢，
你想想，
这四年好惨，
对啊,
但其实来到东京之后，
我们会发现东京这是一个，
有非常多餐饮店的这么一个地方，
这个时候你就有很多可以选择的了，
但是少了很多我直接在学校的那种亲切感，
那肯定的，
东京是一个怎么说比较冷漠的一个城市吧，
你的选择多了，
装潢好了，味道好了，
但是人和人的距离就变得很远，
就可能，
这些中餐的味道都比我在学校的那个店好，
但是他们都没有那个店给我的记忆身，
但是很幸运的是，
我本来东京以后也遇到了一家，
让我有跟之前山里那家店一样感觉的一家店，
虽然它是一家早餐店，
其实我也是，
是因为那个早餐店让我找到了一种亲切感，
你进去了以后就会觉得很踏实，
可能来过日本，
或者说对日本有所了解的朋友们，
可能知道日本是没有早餐的，
可能对于日本人来说的话，
他们吃早餐就是便利店的饭头二三明治，
要不就是街家松屋这种快餐店，
或者有时候还会买麦当勞的，
慢慢分吃，
对,
就是像咱们国内那种传统意义上的早餐，
在日本是没有的，
对,
所以这个时候我就会特别想念国内那个。
热腾腾的豆浆油条都不能，
但是幸运的是，
我们家附近，
其实也不能说是附近了，
开车的话也有10公里，
那么一家早餐店，
它早上6点钟开始定一，
真的就是卖国内的那种早餐，
豆浆油条豆腐脑，
馅饼包子，
馄饨都是人家现做的，
对,
它的距离虽然有点远，
但你去的之后，
我就会觉得特别值得，
这店是一个老夫妻开的，
然后他们全家也都在日本，
那个店所有的吃食，
都是那个大爷自己做的，
然后你要是去的晚了，
你经常会买不到，
可能在东京，
比如说上野，
迟带,
新小言，
穿口,
这些都是传统意义上，
中国人比较多的地方，
那么可能你到了千业，
到了我家这一边，
相对于比较乡下的地方，
或者说是比较偏僻的地方，
很少能看见这么多中国人，
甚至说你很少能看见中国人，
但是那家店，
会让你知道，
原来千业有这么多中国人，
每次去的时候，
外边都有一堆人在排队，
全是每张停车的，
因为它附近没有停车场，
然后呢，
它每条马路也比较安静，
以至于你早晨到那个店附近，
就看见马路边上停着，
一辆一辆接一辆的车，
有打双闪的，没打双闪的，
全是在那家店吃早点买早点，
但这个场景，
我觉得就特别像在国内，
在路边吃早餐的那个感觉，
对,
他们家跟国内唯一的区别，
就是他们家不能在门口摆桌的椅子，
这个其实那天我想来着，
我还想跟他建议一下，
这个应该真不能摆，
真不能，
就是占用了公共空间了，
但是一进店，
就会让我感觉，
想起了回忆当中，
在上学的时候，
在路边他买那个早点的那种感觉，
对,
而且那个店特别有人情味，
又有人情味，又有烟火气，
一进店，人家大大妈问你，
哎呀，今天又来了呀，
今儿吃什么呀，
还吃上次那些吗，
要不就是，
那好长时间没来了，
对,
关键是，
他们价格真的不贵，
当然这个价格不贵，
是跟东京现在的物价比，
绝对不能跟国内比，
你要跟国内比的话，
就贵得没边了，
一个油条七块五，
一个包子十块钱，
对吧，肯定是贵的，
但是跟东京现在的物价比，
它绝对算得上是便宜的，
在东京都内，
你现在吃一根油条的话，
大概是250-350日元一根左右，
但是呢，
在那个店里面，
只需要150日元，
是,
这在现在米面都已经涨价，
尤其米已经涨到5公斤，
快5000块钱的时代，
已经非常便宜了，
已经很便宜了，
我们两个，
之前在东京都内吃过一回，
不是这么早的早餐，
因为那家店是10点才开门，
虽然他卖那些，
所谓的豆浆油条那些早餐，
但是他开门比较晚，
我们俩，
稍微吃了一点，
就花了3000多，
而且还都是那种半成品，
他虽然宣称是手作的，
但是一端上来就知道，
那东西是半成品，
他后面加热了一下就是，
就那样的一顿饭，
我们俩还花了3000多日元，
但是在我们家附近的那个早餐店，
我们两个，
急头白脸吃一顿，
吃鸡眼了那给孩子，
就是吃到撑，
甚至还有剩，
也就吃2000，
那还多说了，
一般都是1000多，
所以我们吃完都内那家早餐之后，
就特别后悔，
就那个钱，
够我们在这吃两顿的了，
吃完那唯一的收获，
就是更加想念，
签议在这家早餐店，
所以这个店，
虽然我们现在不经常去，
因为毕竟，
有一点距离，
然后第二个平时要上班，
周末的话，
可能起不来这么早，
因为你去晚了是真没有，
他那好多人都不是说，
一个两个的买，
那十个八个的买，
对，他们有人过去是进货的，
就几十个包的，
几十个油条，
就这么买的，
所以你去晚了以后，
真的是没有，
像我有时候去的话，
都是在群里面会问一下，
我说还有油条吗，
还有什么馅的包子呀，
有了以后我再过去，
要不就是，
我早上起来，
五点多就出门，
那些雪爹也起不来，
我得给他打包回来，
但是其实我有的时候，
是能起来的了，
那行,
那我们也早上叫你，
不行,
就是我真的很喜欢吃这个店，
像我这种，
周末有时候，
要睡了十二点的人，
我有的时候，
我可以，
六点多就起来，
然后,
跟老饭一块去吃，
吃完了以后，
回来睡个活动觉，
对,
那其实我觉得，
大爷大爷妈，
他们两个都挺辛苦的，
那对呀，
只有早点嘛，
那怎么让凌晨就得起来，
你做早餐的话，
你想六点开始卖的话，
你连着就开始准备了，
怎么多年，
正的七月，
就是个辛苦钱，
他也没赚多少钱，
你哥现在来讲的话，
他们赚的是真不多，
我觉得，
对于他们来说，
赚更多的钱，
倒不如说，
得到更多人的认可来的，
或者说，
做一点感觉有价值的事儿，
对对对，
让自己感觉更有价值，
因为,
你能看得出来，
他们很享受这个过程，
就在他们眼里面，
咱们都是孩子，
过去以后，
你明显能感觉出来，
他们那种慈祥，
照顾这个，
照顾那个，
都是自家孩，
都在外面打拼不容易，
而且我们每次，
还给他顺便，
把那个桌子收拾，
那个大妈还特别感谢我们，
还说说给我们C两个饮料，
我觉得这就是很自然的事儿，
就是你在这里面，
能找到一丝归属感，
就是你在一个陌生的这个国度，
然后突然找到了，
这一个熟悉的一个角落，
让你感受到了，
来自家乡的温暖，
你想把这一点，
仅存的温暖维持住，
所以你就会主动的，
去做一点什么东西，
就比如说，
帮他收拾收拾东西，
带一下顾客，
把人装个东西，
你就会从一个顾客和，
店主的关系，
发展成了一种，
类似于朋友的关系，
大家都在为了这个电号，
希望他可以持久的开下去，
甚至有的时候，
会跟大爷大妈说，
累了又歇两天，
对，尤其是有一点，
大爷回国看病，
那个时候，
确实特别想念这家店，
而且会担心，
对，希望他们可以，
身体健康，
再多开几年，
对,
我们那也是想，
找到一个，
不光是为了吃饭，
也可以成为，
我们在一国塌乡的，
一个,
所谓的避风港，
一样的一个，
店,
它可以不大，
它可以不好吃，
但是,
它可以让我们，
感受到家的温暖，
哎，你说，
会不会因为，
咱们这期节目，
这家店，
变得越来越火，
不会的，
咱们没有这么多人听，
你放心，
第一个咱们节目，
不会有这么多人听，
第二一个，
听咱们节目的人，
在日本生活的，
也非常少，
第三个，
即使他们在日本生活，
能跑到千夜那个倒霉地方，
吃那个早餐的人，
也几乎没有，
不要对自己有，
这么不切实际的幻想，
对不起，我错了，
你还没有这么大的，
影响力，
朋友,
那,
同样的，
在一国塌乡，
打拼的朋友们，
你们在，
工作的那个城市，
工作的那个国家，
找没找到，
你们记一种，
熟悉的那个味道，
也欢迎在，
评论区里面，
跟我们分享一下，
那,
以上就是，
本期节目的，
全部内容了，
感谢你的收听，
这里是饭来张口，
我是老饭，
我是雪梨，
我们下期再见，
拜拜,